first thank you all for staying till the
last session today and so my name is
lampy 1 and the data scientist for max
point and today I'm going to talk about
how to balance scale and the
interpretability in analytical
applications with cycling and
interviewing Messrs so first I want to
introduce the background for this
project so first what we are doing in
max point so you may learn a lot from my
colleagues talk today or yesterday so
next point it's a digital advertising
technology and the business intelligence
company that want to drive local
customers to applying actions like a
visit or purchase install with
measurable results and the technologies
we use including target the right
audience in physical or digital spaces
and we optimize the ad campaigns to
improve advertising efficiency and also
after all a campaign ends and also when
the complaints running we provide
measurements and provide in size to see
well at convenience can improve
ourselves fuller products in stores and
they also as some time we want to find
if there's anything any other
interesting sales drivers for lowes
products and we work with a major brands
retailers and agencies over across
United States and today I want to focus
on measurement and in size so this is
what my projects doing the one very
interesting and the challenging question
let our customers want us to answer is
which factors drive sales for certain
products in their stores and we have
many many data sources very different
data sources to use to answer this
question like lavera theta of example
umbrellas may have better sales when
it's raining so low where they have may
help too
to pray to the cells we have demographic
data that includes gender age and the
type of jobs in the neighborhood so for
example some for some luxury snake um
the energy income in that neighborhood
may have some high correlation with
Lascelles for that product and also we
have data for online copy consumption so
we know which type of web pages let
neighborhood is most interested in so
that type of data may be highly
correlated with some products and also
we have some other type of data where I
didn't put here because the limitation
of space here so with so many Robo
data's and with a go to interpret the
cells for all the products um the
questions like how we can solve this
problem and when we want to tackle this
challenge we found many province and so
in your company we have very lots of
smart understand that they have signed
is what together and all of them have
rang different backgrounds they have
have a different understanding of data
set and the defend modern approaches
it's very hard to compare the prediction
powers among different models and the
amount different it has said because
you'd really use like Python notebook to
do modeling and something even use are
so it's very hard to transfer a Louis
modeling process to the alert to
generalize the modern approach to other
products to compare the prediction
powers among LAN and also lesson
creation between models for example some
product may have some creation with both
valid data and the sonority data so and
also is possible at all so bland can
provide wearing well prediction then how
can we choose one but not choose the
other one and use that to UM 22
to to show to our customer and the lea
local bands that um we want to achar
eyes these modern approaches and
different data set to different products
and we don't just won't lend to be one
tired so so before that um not analyst
doing load molding process using
notebooks so lay after a lenovo get
stung they save it somewhere so if we if
you are interested in layer model in la
nutella said you need to like a email
land or check them online to find the
notebook and start to learn from Los
notebooks so it's not wearing convenient
to generalize those approaches to a new
for new products and also it's not easy
to improve those modern approaches and
also we want to share the knowledge
among different peoples so as a data
scientist the most fun part for me is to
do modeling it's not data processing
data important maybe some land as
interesting to you but not for me so if
I want to do modeling using a data set
and no from mirror I want to um if
somebody else have already done that I
will be very happy to learn from king or
she or her to learn to save my time to
duel of data pre-processing process so
and also for some wearing large of data
set like the only topic it has said so
late they have like um weekly public
consumption for thousands of topics so
it's very hard to redo the data
importing and impure and preprocessing
all this pre-processing post process so
um so we want to approach to share the
knowledge of among different people when
we use the data set to do motoring
and finally we want to combine the
results from different models let's
because for some products like sine
alpha some high-end snakes is possible
it can be impacted by two different
factors so it can be impacted by Allah
and which income level in the
neighborhood it can also be impacted by
the online inches in this neighborhood
so we want a solution to solve all this
province we want a solution that can
allow multiple people to work on this
program parolee because this problem is
very large as you see um we have very
different very different data sources
and also people have different modeling
approaches so will we want to divide
least big problem to resemble subtext
tasks so people could walk on land
paralleling and we won't extensibility
so we want to maintain this project at a
low cost of effort and also we want to
improve this project iteratively and
also it won't lead solution to allow
some flexibility follow motors um so
well when let's new data set to predict
the cells or when the models have a
different modern approaches then we we
need a nice solution to feel um to be
consistent over time and also a lot of s
ability to adjust them and also we want
some transferrin from the motoring
results so a from this model um we want
the consumer of this project to find out
in size from the dataset
see how these factors are correlated
with lascelles sales value of la
products and last we won't
standardization so this will help the
maintenance and the improvement of this
project in a lower one then we come to a
approach with code modo stacking so this
was first proposed by Wofford in 1992 so
this is not a new approach and later he
was translated a in statistical language
by Raymond in 1993 and this approach is
very popular in caigo competition where
people can try different a modern
approaches for prediction than combine
the prediction to generate the strongest
prediction and here is a diagram of the
staking approach and on the left you can
see we partition the data to different
subset of data so this is very unique
this is not a general stacking approach
in general stacking approach actually
the users send it has said to fit the
sub models but for us is very nature to
partition the it has said beforehand
because this data set like weather data
set demography with data set and the
online topic consumption data set they
have very different data importing
process and that they'd have proposed
processing process so its very nature to
partition than beforehand so people are
people can walk home different eres el
perro Lee and then we we use different
regressors to fit this subset of data
set so you can try linear regression
that's saw a regression a random forest
and so on so it depends on your choice
now after you have
actions from those based regreses from
level zero you can stagger those
predictions to at level one where we
have a stacking regresar here to combine
all our predictions from the base
requester to generate a final prediction
so this is the diagram for stacking
approach and as you can see is right
easy when you have a new data set if you
have a for example if you think some
unemployment it has that can have some
correlation with some products cells
then you can simply add a data set here
and fit this and point and employment it
has set using a requester then you add
love prediction from lees regresar to
last accurate aggressive so it's rain
flexible to add a new data set and also
is very flexible to change a new modern
approach you can try different regreses
for different subset of data set you can
try as I said a linear regression or
tree-based the regression here so now
let's look at the coast and coat so how
can we build up a stressor at level 0 so
first we need to construct a abstract
class which is called base regresar here
and less three important abstract messrs
in lees base progress across yeah yep
data feed and predict and I'll get it
our messages just some process to import
data and the most interesting one a Slav
feet measured so i will explain it in a
more concrete eight of concrete regresar
example so here is example for a
concrete concrete base requester and so
so for this one I use the online content
consumption data so this is a data set
where we have the number of different
type of page views that are consumed by
the neighborhood quickly so this dataset
is X here in this function and why it's
a sales data for some product in stores
and then I can determine what
pre-processing steps I want to use to
apply to the data set we can normalize
the data to do imputation to a fueler
missing values in a data set and we can
do logarithm transformation on a data
set and finally we can use a lesser
regresar to combine our two feet the
transformed data set and finally we can
make up pipeline using older steps we
have defined we had determined in order
so least step have invitation neither
and the lock rear end transformation and
the soul so all these components are
exactly learn so you don't need to write
rent detailed code to implement this
method orange and using a pipeline is
very easy to UM feed the data so if you
call applied off feat X Y then you will
go through all the steps you have
determined beforehand so you will first
impute love um X data set then do number
is a shin then do log transformation
then lastly use the transformed X data
set to fit why the sales value here
using lasso regresar so it's all
predetermined pipeline and last you can
save the pipeline into a model in the
class so as using
previous slides i use pipeline to
automate the fitting process for a base
regresar so it's wearing handy and
usually when we do modeling last three
different steps that it have preparation
feature extraction and modeling and for
each step you can look up in some like
cyclin package to find local responding
modules for example if you do imputation
then you can use the computer from
succulent pre-processing package and
also that's something timbra
corresponding factories here are modules
here and similarly you can look up the
feature selection package to do feature
selection and if you want to do pc you
can use at pca decomposition Duquette
pca to do dimensionality reduction and
also there are lots of choice exactly
learn models gdynia model tree model and
random forests and so on so you have
right variety of choices and improve its
example we have determined how to
process up our data then you can just
simply make a pipeline using hola Alamo
modules you have chosen in the order you
want to process the data and after you
feed your pipeline using your data set
you can easily retrieve the detailed
information for the pipeline you can see
the detail information for each step and
also you can see like what's that you
have included in the pipeline and you
can also look up the intermediate
results of the some steps in the
pipeline so this is ranked convenient
okay so we have talked about how to
build based regressors then the next
question is like how can we stacker
those space regressors to form a stacker
and here h say is a base regresar and
hcn is a stacking regresar so stacking
regresar is a linear combination of base
regressors and the question here is
actually how to find the optimal ways to
combine the results from the base
regressors so one natural solution is to
use the square feet to find the optimal
ways beta here to come to combine the
base regressors however you need to pay
attention to two things first is that
actually you cannot use less than
dataset to feed base regreses and the
stacker regreses at the same time
because of the overfitting issue so
employments paper it suggests us to use
leave-one-out estimate from the base
regresar and use let this one out it's
made to do stuff eating for stackers
however it's raining time consuming
because to estimate a live one out um
you need to iterate over different roles
in the data set so its running time
consuming so to trade off we actually
use variation set approach so we split
the data to test um to training set and
the test lab set and we filter based
requesters using a training set and we
fit the stacker steps taking regressors
using the test set and we other
important things that you need some
restriction on the weight beta so beta
house should be non-negative the
intuition is that you if you want to put
some bass regresar into la stacker then
if the weight is negative that means
this replaced regresar is not performing
well so there's no reason to put learn
English regresar sorry to put the
English taking
reser actually so you can simply get rid
of that base regresar so that's why the
we we can have a restriction that the
other ways should be non-negative and
also magically it can fix the
multicollinearity issue so um because we
have different many different base
progresses or and Oakland have the same
goal they want to predict the sales data
a sales value for some product so let us
somehow correlate it with each other so
by enforcing this restriction you can
see the multicollinearity issue is fixed
by this and after combining the base
professors using a please approach we
can find a final result is better than a
best bass regresar and also for some
unknown psirico in practice a tree is
better enriched regression for some
unknown reason is not theoretical is
friend at least I didn't find any paper
on that but in practice is better
enriched regression so rich the question
is approached another approach to
combine the base professors and it can
fix the multicollinearity issue but in
terms of accuracy this approach is
better'n which regression regression and
after um combining the base regressors
then a tree we can use likelihood ratio
test to rent the importance for each
base to go full of base regressors and
now let's look some code again and Lord
stacking regresar is a cross and this
cross take to impose the list of base
regressors endless stacking regreses you
choose to putting so you take these two
as a man argument to in
good and remember that we have a
constraint that other way should be
non-negative so when we determine we let
me define a stacking requester we define
a default stacking requester which is a
called combiner here so it's a lasso
regresar with spring small alpha value
so that means actually we don't use the
l1 realization peanutty at all and we
enforce all the coefficients to be
positive so that current them make sure
that all the ways are non-negative so
this is our default stake us taking
regresar so you have the flexibility to
try a low regreses like rich reversal or
less all the other type of the soul
aggressor but the default is the one
suggested in the paper and then let's
look look at how we can fit the stacking
regresar so first we split the data set
to training data set and test data set
and so here Lee the estimators a lot
based regressors so we use the training
data set to feed the base regressors
hello Roley and using those fitted base
professors we use the test data set to
do predictions so we have stack of
predictions from the base regressors
using the test data set and then we use
new stack of predictions from base
regressors and the true sales values
from the test dataset to feed law
stacking regresar
so this is our major process for fitting
the stacking regressors and now let's
look at how it applies to our our cases
and here we show the results for two
different type of products one is some
insect repellent product and yellow is
some high-end snake product and the both
of them have about 30 weeks of data for
about 200 stores and here we use four
different based regressors that
demographic model using principal
component regression where a model using
linear mixed-effects regression we
commence model using random forests
regression and online content
consumption model using lasso regression
so you may ask why I choose these
different regression models for
different data set especially for a week
of mouse model why choose random forests
it doesn't think make sense so um the
idea is to try even thing for different
they are set and to try something not
that good to see if our stacker can pick
the good ones from the bad ones and here
is low a square value for different
levels of four regressors so a square
value is a Alex it's low variance
explained by the modal so the higher a
squirrel then that means the Battle of
model is and as you can select the
stacker the stacking requester always
have highest a square value and is
higher than the no best base progressor
like the weather model here for the
insect repellent compan
and also for this one is better than the
best based requester which you use the
content consumption data here and also
this model is wearing transparent so you
can rank the base regressors using
likelihood ratio test so because after
we predict the sales value our customers
are interesting which type of data is
most important for the cells so this one
is try to answer this question so follow
insect repellent product you can see a
weather model is fast for the high-end
snake product you can see the content
consumption model is fast and another
cool thing is that you can continue
ticking you can you may your customer
may continue ask you what are the most
important features in the weather model
so you can continue ticking and find the
most important features in the weather
database and you know well as up data so
here you can see the temperature
humidity wind a lot ops three important
features follow where a model for the
insect repellent data and similarly you
can find the beauty and health topic is
most important topic in law content
online content consumption data for a
snake product and also you can visualize
your results by prada scatter plot using
the top important features for the data
set so here's a scatter plot of the top
three important features from the
weather data set versus less weekly
sales data set and this is for law
insect repellent compan so as you can
see when it's hot and humid and there's
no much wind like in insect repellents
have better cells so that makes sense
and so this is um why I have done for
the stacking approach so let's go to
lock conclusion and to conclude i
introduce a how to butte stack
regression and lat two key component one
is la-based regressors and the other is
the stacking regresar and first we split
the data set to training data set and
the test data set and we fit the base
requester using the training data set
because we want to avoid overfitting
issue and the advantage for a base
requesters let you can work on these
parolee so many people can work on this
project and also it's very easy to add a
new data set and try different model
approach on that data set and we
standardize the implementation using
sakky learn pipeline package since
wearing handy and the results from the
base regresar is rain transparent so you
can see what other important features in
the base regression to fit the stacking
regresar we use that has data set and we
use this square feet to find the optimal
Nanak non negative ways to combine the
base requesters and a result for
stacking regreses always better than the
best best base regresar and also we can
find an important base regressors using
likelihood ratio test so actually this
is a test to measure in the impact of
adding
based regresar into a stacker and then
we show two case studies to demonstrate
that these hooks for different it has
that and I want to thank my colleagues
Josh Patrick Alex cow because they
contribute a lot for this project and
it's time for questions questions thank
you Oh have one question of when you
choose a model for example whether model
you choose the random forest do you ever
tried other model for the weather later
you get the same results uh so the
question is that where um I have tried
other models for data set for ya besides
random forest so uh so this is a good
question so um so yeah we tried a lot
models um but because actually this data
said it's not wearing good dsl so every
other models on a weaker months data set
is not performing well but for alidade i
said like hoppy consumption data set we
try a besides LA so we tried random
forest and like a rich regression so we
tried many different modern approaches
only data set so the advantage of this
approach is that you can try as many
modern approaches as you know or one
dataset and pick the best one for that
data set and save that and you can use
that for other products so let's let
answer your question
did you you tied it but you get
different two sons different ranking
that's water but if I the same data or
sad different model do you get a same
ranking like I uh not not um it depends
a quality of love modeling yeah if you
try out different yet we try two
different approaches if that approach it
doesn't have brain different without
spoon like the random forest is not that
different from that so natural rank will
no change but we try writing bad like a
modern approach like linear regression
for wearing high dimensional data then
the ranking will change okay thank you
do you have any plot or the comparison
how stacking regresar perform well
compared to single regresar uh yes so I
have one hey Bo showing that so is this
square for different level request so
the bottom row is full stacking regresar
but in that case you didn't combine the
for the single regresar you didn't
combine all training sets you just two
separate the training set and get the
result and stacked the model actually
helped all training sets different
different data and has the definitely
she will have much better uh yeah that's
a good question so yeah actually this
one is not just you slit rent on the
test data actually yeah it used like a
different test data so um so for example
demographics weathers we if we combine
then we probably get better
oh yes so yeah actually I yeah so sorry
so actually yeah for this model I I
didn't useless some models there um no
fitting submodel here a tree I used the
whole data set to Chen these some models
and computer asker's so it's not using
the training dataset to feel a model i
use law a combination of training and
the test data to fit the some models and
dual a comparison so so actually yeah
it's confusing here because let some
models here and not very the sub
component they are using different it
has a two feet because as you said it's
unfair to compare if they are using
different data set to fit because the
second model have more data set for
chaining so for here a tree I so full of
some models i use a whole dataset to
feed it again to computers quarters i
think this is this might be right you
know you have two ways one is just use
all the data and choose the best model
or you can use some other ways to
combine combining several models
together together a better one usually
it's kind of combining example method of
you give you better results in the
literature so there there are several
ways to combine a models into a single
better one so this stacking is one
method and there there are some other
ways like a boosting of bagging did you
try other ways to combine several models
into one also obviously there is no
single winner among the three each each
methodist has its own advantage i
believe so for example does stacking
matter will give you a better no
accuracy and maybe I think begging give
you a variable deduction and better
variable so dear did you try other
I in some bowling matter um yes and for
some cases like boosting and bagging
have better results but here we also
want to the result to be transparent
solely stacking approaches more linear
so it's easier to interpret the results
in this approach so it's a trade-off
between accuracy and the
interpretability so accuracy is not uh
no ho sorry yes you are correct that
kind of transparent and easy easily kind
of tracked that your training set and
that the prediction result but as bill
mentioned probably begging or boosting
may have better performance compared to
steck model because it's quite linear
you mean boosting and bagging others
Unser's so I so so I think their
characters there may be no not one
single winner here's as I said different
models have different advantage stacking
is a very good method to compare it with
boosting and the bagging the tea you
know there's like you said there's Chad
off here sir yeah
so I was curious if you were too so for
insect repellent weather is obviously
guiding a lot of your prediction here
would it make sense to have to base
regressors for whether one with you know
like a random forest and one with the
other thing or would that start over
fitting um yeah that's a good question
so yeah you can do that but a brain slow
difficulty in to pray to the data if
like both of them like contribute a beat
in love stacking land is hard to like
computer importance for the two to base
requesters together so yeah it can
improve the accuracy but in terms of
interpretability is hard to integrate
using two different models at the same
time and with that we have to cut it um
let's take long way and any further
questions